hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in chapter 8 of book three of his work
on anger Seneca is going to give us some
very useful advice about the kind of
people that we associate with we engage
with we surround ourselves with and he's
recognizing that if we want to lessen
our anger it's not enough to just get
ourselves under control we need to think
about who we engage with because we're
not perfect beings who can snap our
fingers and automatically have control
and a proper perspective we are going to
be affected by the people that we see
day to day and who we're engaged with
and I think that in in an age of social
media and you know 24-hour news
availability which most of which is
opinion or speculation rather than hard
news this is especially important we
need to think about who we're actually
be involved with so he's got this great
line since we don't know how to Bear how
to carry literally a wrong and in
urea let's avoid taking one let's avoid
taking on uh something that will lead us
to anger hear the translation we should
we should take care not to suffer a
wrong and so he says
our intimate should be very calm and
easy to get along with not nervous and
cross-grained so he's going to expand on
that in a bit when he talks about the
virtuous
but here's a key important idea we pick
up habits Morris right our customs our
ways of approaching things from our
companions the people that we are
surrounding ourselves with that we're
engaging with and thereby he says that
here's the translation just as some
disorders now disorders here is vitia
which is more literally vices some
disorders are transmitted by bodily
contact so the Mind passes on its
defects to those closest at hand and
he's got three very interesting and
relatable examples here drunkards people
who drink too much get drunk you know do
stupid things right he says that a
drunkard has made his table mates fond
of unmixed wine you might say well
what's wrong with unmixed wine well in
ancient Greece and Rome in the
Mediterranean in general you would have
wine and then you would mix it with
water so that you wouldn't get as drunk
on it just as people in you know places
like Britain would drink weaker beer
during the day so that they wouldn't go
back to work all all drunk
right so uh drinking unmixed wine as a
habit is sort of like drinking hard
liquor for us drunkards will encourage
that because you know they're doing that
themselves they want you to participate
in it he talks about the sexually
abandoned and that's a translation of
impuricorum right you don't want to hang
out with these people because you
yourself are going to start becoming too
loose and lacks in your own morals right
a greedy person somebody who is
Afflicted with avarice avaricia has
transmitted his infection to his
neighbors now it's very interesting that
Seneca brings these up because these do
in fact fall in a classification that we
will see later on among Christian
authors not too far from here as the
eight Capital vices or the seven deadly
sins these are among the you know three
first gluttony also includes getting
drunk lost and greed right so there's a
recognition back in seneca's time that
these are not good ways to be and if you
don't want to pick up those habits
maybe you shouldn't be hanging around
people like that or again if we want to
think about in the age of the internet
maybe you shouldn't be engaging in
communities or consuming content that
figures in with this because it
encourages bad Tendencies now the
virtues as he says do the opposite
he says it's the same way with virtues
but in Reverse they make mild everything
that is within their orbit just as poor
health profits from being in an
advantageous region and a more healthy
climate so if you want to improve Minds
wanting and strength profit from keeping
company with a better crowd if you want
to improve yourself hang around with
people who are better off morally
speaking people who don't have to get
drunk or high or you know eat too much
people who you know can't actually uh
you know as we say keep it in their
pants people who aren't greedy people
who aren't subject to a lot of these
other things that we're going to talk
about as well and not only are not
subject to them but have a positive
disposition this will improve you and he
gives this interesting example you'll
understand how effective this is if
you've seen that even wild animals
become gentle from living with us all
harshness is smoothed away and unlearned
little by little in Placid company and
so then he says you know it's like that
with
um you know us human beings we not only
get a good example from these people but
because we're hanging out with them we
lack reasons to get angry unless we get
angry at the fact that they're good or
something and then we're really in
trouble and we don't indulge The Vices
while we're involved with them so if we
want to avoid getting angry we need to
hang out with people who don't uh
themselves succumb to that and then he
goes on a little bit further and he says
there's a number of other people that we
should avoid now it's not just because
they have habits that we might contract
as a vice or a disease it's because they
are the kind of people that are liable
to provoke our anger precisely because
of their character and the
characteristic actions or attitudes that
this leads to on their part and he's
actually got nine different categories
that he brings up so first we have the
Arrogant or the prideful the superbee
they will offend you with their contempt
right they're looking down on you you
get mad about that uh a smart mouth
right somebody who talks smack as we say
a decox will offend you how by saying
things that you don't like to to hear
with an insult an unruly person
petulance we get the word petulant from
that they will
bother you with their their injuries a
spiteful lividus we get livid from this
somebody who just wants to hurt you with
their maliciousness their malice their
doing harm to you for no good reason an
aggressive person pugnax literally
somebody wants to fight with you
trying to provoke fights right you got
to really watch out for them and then
we've got this lying wind bag and this
is great because there's actually two
terms here ventosis full of wind at
mendocs a liar right somebody who twists
the truth and tells lies why with their
vanity
and then he says you won't put up with
being viewed suspiciously by the fearful
timari we don't like when people exhibit
suspicion toward us when they don't
trust us
um you won't uh run into problems being
bested by the stubborn the pertinake
right pertinox
um or the over refined the uh delicator
right the the people who are turning
their nose up at you they they think oh
your clothes aren't good enough the
things you you don't drink aren't good
enough right all of these are people who
could tick us off so what seneca's
advice
avoid them minimize your contact with
them try not to have anything to do with
them as far as you can if you see that
somebody's like that say well I don't
want to be around them because they're
just going to make me mad and I don't
want to get mad they can do their thing
right these are people that we know are
going to goad us to anger and notice the
two terms that he's using there
right they are irritating and they lead
to us feeling angry iracundium right so
we want to try to minimize that as much
as possible again to the contrary we
should pick other types of people he
says more beneficial will be those who
are sweet tempered simply case
straightforward is another way of
expressing it they're not they're
sincere is another good term affable
faciles easy to get along with faculty
it means easy right or self-control
moderatos people who who don't need to
indulge themselves in all of these
vicious types of behavior and
comportment right we want those why
because they'll neither provoke your
anger nor will they put up with it
um he says uh you know uh we want these
people not to the point though of being
Yes Men because excessive compliance
or literally
um
a sentatio
um giving a scent agreeing with being
too agreeable we don't want people like
that because they tend to provoke anger
and what We're translating there is Yes
Men in adulation the people who are butt
kissers the people who are flatterers
the people who go along too much we do
want friends who can say to us hey man
you need to chill out you need to take
it easy and he goes on a little bit
later and talks about these he says if
we know we're quick to anger pick
companions like this the sort to follow
our looks and utterances to be sure
they'll spoil us and put us in a bad
habit of hearing nothing against our
wishes but they'll do us the service of
giving our anger a bit of quiet time
even those who are naturally difficult
and violent will put up with somebody
who sweet talks them right now he does
actually talk about uh a person that he
knows this orator kelius extreme
extremely irascible right he was dining
in his private chamber with a client
whose forbearance was Exquisite though
finding himself in those Close Quarters
he had a hard time avoiding a quarrel
with his Patron he reckoned it best to
follow along with whatever Kalia said
and play second fiddle calius couldn't
bear this continuous agreement and
shouted contradict me at it somehow so
there will be two of us but even calius
he says angry because the other didn't
become angry soon left off finding
himself without an opponent so you know
we have this good tendency we can
develop towards having a good temper
with respect to anger we have our
problems over here our vices we want to
have companions who are if they're not
at least you know virtuous maybe just
getting along with us not provoking us
with all of this other stuff that is
going to lead us into feeling anger at
them and then you know probably even
getting a little angry at ourselves
first screwing up so Seneca thinks that
it's really important the people that we
choose to spend our time with the people
that we give our space and our you know
mental uh attention to and as I
mentioned before as we close this up in
an age of social media and
interconnectivity we want to thank very
much not just about the people that were
in face-to-face contact with but about
people that we spend time with online
are we choosing to spend time with
people who are going to Goat us into
anger who are going to tick us off who
are going to make us worse off
or are we choosing to spend time with
other people who provide us with a good
example and will sometimes either call
us on our nonsense or at least give us
the space and time to cool off and say
hey man you need to take it easy a
little bit this is a very important
consideration if we want to improve our
our you know attitude and our
assumptions and our habits with respect
to anger not just for today but for our
life going forward